I wore this shirt today because I wanted
to support Kim you heard that right Blac
Chyna supporting Kim Kardashian one year
after losing her defamation lawsuit
against the reality star and her famous
family what's going on during a recent
sit down with the why the game chose me
podcast the model rocks a shirt
featuring Kim posing for Dolce and
Gabbana nice shark there
oh this
is
I wore this shirt today because I wanted
to support him just to run down some
important backstory many years ago Kim
and China used to be friends
oh my gosh
hello
then they became family when China
welcomed a daughter dream with her now
ex Kim's brother Rob Kardashian the two
even had a short-lived reality show
which documented their tumultuous
relationship
[Music]
you treat people like your rose and
you're inconsiderate when I'm doing
everything you ask whatever get out of
my face so yeah China supporting her
ex's sister is unexpected she did a
collaboration with Dolce and I I respect
it you know and his dreams on teams so
okay this is cool I think it's cool of
course this is a major change of tune
for China who sued Kim and several
members of her family last year for
defamation But ultimately lost the case
the mother of my brother's daughter is
suing me Kylie Kimberly and my mom for
defamation and interference with the
contract she is saying that the Rob and
China show
didn't get a second season because we
interfered with it not because they
weren't in a relationship anymore the
trial was discussed on the famous
family's Hulu series and cameras were
rolling as they received the verdict
we won
that all went down in May 2022 and since
then China seemingly turned a corner
she's been baptized and in the name of
the Holy Ghost and she's been
documenting her journey to Wellness on
social media reversing the Cosmetic work
she had done on her breasts and backside
from the best decisions I could have
done in a very long time China who now
goes by her birth name Angela White also
dissolved the fillers from her face it
like totally changed my face and I'm
just I'm ready to get back to Angela
it's just time for like a change and
over the weekend China shared the
process of having a demonic tattoo
removed from her hip so
y'all know that I had this Baphomet
tattoo right
it gots to come off I just don't want
anything negative or demonic on my body
anymore so yeah lots of changes for
China physically and spiritually and
we'll just have to stay tuned to see if
Kim responds to China's support
[Music]